si à tous bon soir françois bayrou merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors on l'entendait campagne difficile
pour le modem avec des défections avec
des divisions et des sondages qui vous
place à moins de 5% est ce que le modem
est en perdition des questions fondée
uniquement sur les sondages uniquement
sur le climat général isik roma sur les
sont non uniquement sur les sondages
il ya eu aussi jeune et il est
effectivement y en a eu non il ya eu 2
je crois deux personnes qui trouvaient
pas leur place sur la liste qui sont
allés sur une autre ce qui sur un parti
et près de là quelques départs et devant
un obstacle
ça n'est pas le sujet jacques attali
aujourd'hui a écrit un article que vous
avez peut-être lu que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant édition continue à avoir
comme seule préoccupation que les
sondages dans une campagne électorale
les sondages mais s'il vous plaît
c'est la question que vous avez posé si
on continue à avoir comme seule
préoccupation que les sondages dans une
campagne électorale régionale
il n'y a aucune chance que la démocratie
française trouve notre vie en commun
trouve un équilibre minimale aucune
chance et donc toutes ces spéculations
je n'y crois pas j'ai une absolue
confiance dans le lien avec des
électeurs et dans la qualité de ce que
nous présentons via de voir alain dolium
c'est un homme je crois tout ce qu'ils
ont rencontrés c'est un jeune homme à
l'origine un en effet de la diversité 7
c'est un signe qui a du sens de la
diversité comme on dit parce qu'il est
d'origine antillaise
c'est quelqu'un qui a quelque chose à
dire parce qu'il a vécu
le parcours des sites et jusqu'à la
création d'entreprises et à l'emploi
alors là ce ne sont pas des sondages
c'est le commentaire l'affirmation de
claude bartolone pour le parti
socialiste qui juge sans doute aussi au
vu de ces sondages que le vrai pari
gagné par martine aubry aux régionales
sera d'avoir restreint la place du modem
d'avoir réduit la place du modem
quelle est votre réaction ah si vraiment
c'est ça un but dans la vie
alors on n'a pas tout à fait la même
conception des choses je vais vous dire
je croyais que cette gauche n'existait
plus je croyais que la gauche sectaire
fermée bêtasse comme ça qu'ils élisent
qui dit je ne travaillerai jamais avec
des gens qui n'ont pas mon étiquette
je croyais que ça n'existait plus je
pensais que les événements la victoire
de nicolas sarkozy la politique mise en
place qui donne lieu à de très profondes
réserves et les difficultés qu'on a vu
rencontrées par les gens je croyais que
ça avait ouvert l'esprit de certains et
cette fausse dans les raisins 2000 en
temps réel vous attendez j'ai pas fini
et cette gauche là sectaire est fermé je
ne m'entendrez jamais avec elle et je
ferai tout ce que je peux vous incluez
marc le bris
non pas du tout pour que j'espère que
non mais elle le dira je ferai tout ce
que je peux pour que cette attitude de
de sectarisme n'occupent pas les
responsabilités en france et pas non
plus dans les régions je suis prêt à
travailler avec des responsables de
gauche ou verts intelligents il y en a
il y en a beaucoup
je crois que c'est même la majorité mais
les attitudes de 1 fermeture et
d'exclusion pour moi c'est très simple
je dis jamais alors un mot sur ce
calendrier présenté en quelque sorte par
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui pas de pause
dans l'immédiat pas de changement de cap
on à dimanche des élections régionales
david pujadas régional de ces élections
régionales excusez moi de vous le dire
c'est pas pour vous faire un procès
direct on n'a pas dit un mot
et vous même vos débuts vous l'aviez
parlez vous pas du maillot national pas
du tout vous vous trompez
j'ai dit exactement 24 janvier et si je
voulais c'est faire l'interview comme
vous voulez la faire on arriverait au
bout de l'interview on n'aurait pas
parlé des régions en iard et alors je
veux vous dire quelque chose
les régions pourraient puissamment aidé
les gens des régions pourraient
puissamment aidé
les français dans leur vie de tous les
jours on a vu un peu plus tôt là dans
votre journal des actes de violence dans
une université qui sont absolument
insensé les universités manque
cruellement d'encadrement j'étais à
saint-etienne avec valeria a priori
j'étais à saintes et messi il faut
qu'elle le fasse
on prend lorsque vous êtes une région
vous avez comme on dit la clause de
compétence générale vous pouvez prendre
des initiatives vous savez que les
régions interviennent souvent dans les
universités et heureusement j'étais avec
azouz begag à saint-etienne et bien
azouz begag et moi nous avons vu la très
belle bibliothèque de l'université qui
vient d'être construite elle ferme à six
heures du soir
elle ferme à six heures du soir pourquoi
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'encadrement
minimal il ya des dizaines de milliers
d'étudiants qui cherche des ressources
pour pouvoir faire leurs études pour
qu'on leur propose pas un contrat une
bourse solide contre 1 l'encadrement des
buts de teck universitaire ou contre le
tutorat pour des jeunes étudiants ça
peut changer la vie des gens s'appelait
rechange sur l'emploi vous voyez si je
vous avais laissé faire on faisait
l'interview sans dire un mot des régions
heureusement qu'on peut dire que des
régions bien conduite
elles peuvent aider les gens dans leur
vie ce aurait dû être le sujet de la
campagne électorale en tout cas pour
nous ça le sera merci françois bayrou
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et on
retient voyez votre suggestion pour les
régions et pour les universités